on s'y attendait c'est fait
bombardements aériens déploiement de
soldats déjà 15 morts au moins dont huit
civils selon l'observatoire syrien la
turquie a lancé une offensive contre les
forces kurdes dans le nord-est de la
syrie le président turc à la prix nous
l'appelons tout le temps en fait
l'opération paix du printemps
neutralisera les menaces terroristes qui
pèsent contre la turquie et permettra
d'établir une zone sécuritaire pour
faciliter le retour des syriens dans
leur pays
la communauté internationale a vivement
réagi aujourd'hui la ministre des
affaires étrangères christophe hullin a
fermement condamné l' incursion turc et
je reçois la réalisatrice québécoise
d'origine kurde design et akyol elle
rentre tout juste de cette région on l'a
été à la rencontre de jihadistes pour
tourner un documentaire dont la sortie
est prévue en 2021 bonsoir madame nicole
et on se mange des bretons oui oui et
d'ailleurs les gens vous connaissent
peut-être à travers votre autre
documentaire gaulliste en terre des
roses qu'on peut voir d'ailleurs sur le
site de louer n'est ce pas alors vous
rentrez vous êtes passé quatre mois là
bas dans cette zone qui est qui est en
guerre maintenant 10 normalement
aujourd'hui
oui c'est ça je suis rentré lundi et là
j'ai tourné mon documentaire donc c'est
sûr les les gens qui ont adhéré à l'état
islamique pourquoi ils l'ont fait entre
autres pour les étrangers c'est de
comprendre pourquoi le est fait et aussi
pour les séries et irak et donc
qu'est-ce qui les avait poussé à adhérer
ce couple c'est que c'est quoi leur
mentalité sont sortes de sujets que vous
allez pouvoir vous parler la langue des
évidemment je parle pas arabe et
je parle une cure des tueries c'est déjà
beaucoup pour les autres
oui mais j'ai fait des entrevues en
plusieurs langues avec des traducteurs
donc avait des russes des français des
belges des allemands
des cyber du côté d'evian s'était déjà
dit ce détenu
oui détenus donc en prison par les
cannois est donc aujourd'hui c'est la
principale inquiétude de l'occident
c'est de voir libérer ces jihadistes la
partie dans la nature est ce que ce
crâne que vous partagez absolument parce
que la turquie attaques des villes qui
sont frontalières au coeur donc au coeur
de la sérié et dont j'ai visité ces
prisons là qu'ils se trouvent et sont
extrêmement proches de la frontière
donc c'est possible mais les kurdes ou
même le disais donc les ziani se
retrouver libre à ce moment là s'il ya
une bonne entente avec la taille de la
terre
oui il ya à peu près plus de cent mille
détenus jen famille oui oui sur 1100
plus de cent mille jeux déjà dans les
trois camps ce que j'ai visité ces
lesquin principalement pour les femmes
et enfin de djihadistes donc analyse sa
jauge et à l rôle ça regroupe déjà cent
mille personnes familles les ans c'est
inimaginable c'est qu'une grosse ville
en réalité absolue ces gens là et sont
détenus
c'est les kurdes qui en ont la
responsabilité et finance commence ici
les kurdes doivent d'abord se défendre
on a vu qu'ils sont prêts à tout pour se
défendre contre la turquie
ils vont abandonner cette responsabilité
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire mais je
pense que oui je pense qu'ils vont de
son - mettre leur énergie à défendre
leur territoire
et là ça c'est un gros problème non
seulement pour les kurdes mais aussi
c'est un gros problème international
parce que oui parce qu'il ya plusieurs
plusieurs milliers de combattants
étrangers comment j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer d'interviews et comprendre un
peu qu'est ce qui se passe et ils sont
pour moi il radicalise et aujourd'hui
non pas du tout non pas de remords n'y a
pas de regrets
art ah oui pourquoi d'après vous avec
les atrocités qu'on a vus mais parce
qu'ils sont c'est une biologiques sont
en forte donc il y croit c'est pas
simplement parce que sont pas forcés
enfin ces actes là c'est c'est un islam
radical et donc il croit au djihad y
croit ou fait qu'il faut éliminer tous
les infidèles les crois au fait qu'il
faut faire une terre islamique
enfin encore un califat même les femmes
les femmes louis on dit souvent qu elles
sont même très radicale faisait
elle-même
oui absolument des leçons et vous et
vous échanges avec les cures donc mieux
se défendre aujourd'hui avec quelques
inquiétudes de manifester parce que
cette partie le jour où trump a annoncé
qu'ils retiraient
une centaine de soldats mais c'est
important mais c'est comme si considéré
comme un abandon de la part des états
unis des occidentaux face à eux
je pense qu'il s'y attendait parce que
depuis décembre à peu près que 30 menace
de retirer les troupes dont qui s'y
attendait c'était était dévastée par
contre par ça parce que je pense qu'il
n'y croyait plus de moi peut-être qu'ils
disaient que ça allait parce que c'est
quand même une collaboration de plus de
cinq ans avec les américains il espérait
que les américains les abandonnerait pas
de cette façon là là ça ça se passe
c'est c'est un génocide qui se prétend
c'est une crise humanitaire une crise de
réfugiés qui va continuer et et ont une
responsabilité je pense
dans tout l'est parce que ça c'est un
problème international
c'est plus un problème de la série dogan
et vise l'élimination complète des
kurdes
oui mais en fait ce qu'il dit c'est
qu'il vise est visé il vise les sdf donc
les forces démocratiques syriennes qui
sont par contre majorité kurde annoncée
par l'occident est financé par
l'occident le policier est aidé par la
coalition donc c'est un double jeu puis
aussi pour avant interview beaucoup de
djihadistes on dit souvent que la
turquie les laisser penser donc
librement la frontière parce que ça
aurait été assez facile pour la turquie
de les arrêter
donc ils ont pensé de la librement
nous arrivons dans le documentaire
plusieurs témoignages disent qu'ils ont
été la porte était ouverte ils ont pensé
qu'ils ont été entraînées par des
commandants turcs qui ont été soignés
dans les hôpitaux turcs
donc ce double jeu lun je pense qu'il
faut il faut faut que ça arrête tout
qu'on en ait conscience aussi de ce qui
se passe
il trempe qui souffle chaud et le froid
parce que verdone essentiel la mise à
l'aller à la maison blanche le 13
novembre
on sait que trump a une double tour
trump à istanbul il dit menace d'imposer
des sanctions souffle le chaud et le
froid
mais l'impact d'après vous sur le
terrain de l'abandon par les américains
mais c'est une crise humanitaire s'agit
nos sites qui se prépare parce qu'on
veut des kurdes potentiel est
essentiellement là c'est uniquement la
région du nord-est la série donc c'est
un génocide et
c'est une crise maintenant je sais
l'idée d'accueillir des réfugiés de
permettre aux syriens réfugiés syriens
qui sont en turquie de retourner c'est à
diluer la population kurde de syrie
vous croyez que les kurdes en la
capacité de combattre notre sortie
non parce que c'est c'est souvent les
bombardements aériens et les kurdes ont
pas l'artillerie ne sont pas équipés
pour ça c'est quand ils faisaient la
guerre contre la neige c'était
essentiellement des américains qui
coupent bombardaient de façon aérienne
et les kurdes sur le territoire donc sur
le terrain
et votre témoignage est absolument
bouleversant est important merci d'abord
été avec nous ce soir c'est trop bref
j'espère qu'on ressort part du vélo ou
aussi diverses l'invitation mercier